aleppo
a city ravaged by years of war and one
of the hardest places in the world
to be a medic and it's here at the dara
shiva hospital
that mohammed qarjud trained to become a
doctor
today he's fighting another kind of
battle against
covid19 in a hospital in york
he's done this for months and he's
exhausted
everyone here is i will always remember
the first covet patient
i say an emergency department
you can't just forget someone who
repeatedly
saying i can't breathe i can't breathe
he's a doctor who knows about losing the
fight for life working in a hospital
that could be pumped
and attacked at any moment he's
experienced appalling pain and agony
he's experienced loss when the hospital
was
attacked severely and completely
destroyed we couldn't get anyone
alive all of them were dead more than 30
people i realized
my best friend died
the hardest part of the job whichever
front line he's on
is always the same to prioritize
patients
and decide to leave whoever you think
you can't do anything for them because
their injuries are just like
too complicated and you don't think they
will make it no matter what you do
for them
today there are rising concerns of
post-traumatic stress disorder amongst
nhs staff
and calls for an urgent plan to address
mental health issues
which experts say could last years after
the immediate threat of the virus has
gone
most people will remember kermit as a
lockdown and not being
able to function as normal for
healthcare workers is completely
different matter
they will carry on having memories of
patients
they couldn't help they could see them
dying in front of their eyes
not being able to do anything like many
on the front line
dr khajud tries to find peace and calm
away from the constant pressure
of the emergency rooms
[Music]
it doesn't last for long in this crisis
but he knows about pressure
and the lessons he learnt in syria are
now part of britain's fight against
covid19 sadia chowdhury sky news
in york